[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous êtes
dans sa zone
qu'a dit ce matin notre invité jean
philippe miller bonjour bonjour bonjour
à tous les auditeurs de marthe ce n'est
que la première dauphine est ni leurs
députés élus dans la 4e circonscription
de la martinique vous êtes également
conseiller territorial la ctm et le
coprésident du parti pays à on précise
que à l'assemblée nationale française
vous appartenait au groupe gdr gauche
démocrate et républicaine qui compte à
peu près 16 députés c'est ça je crois
dont beaucoup du parti communiste
français voilà alors jean philippe
miller évidemment l'actualité politique
ce sont les préparatifs des élections de
juin prochain à la collectivité
territoriale de martinique les candidats
se font un peu plus nombreux depuis
quelques semaines nous en sommes à 6
désormais officiellement et il en reste
encore qui ne se sont pas déclarés dont
la tête de liste de pays on ne la
connaît pas encore
alors d'abord ce nombre qui forcément
forcément sera exponentielle certains
parlent d'une dizaine de listes
peut-être qu'ils seront donc la présente
est ce que c'est une bonne chose et puis
à quand la précision de la tête de liste
pour pays à ce que nous avons déjà
affirmer très clairement c'est que nous
serons présents et bien présent dans
cette bataille électorale prévue au mois
de juin prochain
la dispersion des voix qui risquent de
résulter de la multiplication des
candidatures ce phénomène qui peut être
inquiétant
parce qu'en réalité on sent bien qu en
martinique aujourd'hui la population
martiniquaise
on a assez de l'alternance entre mime et
ppm et je crois que aujourd'hui dont
dans le sentiment d'une grande partie de
la population martiniquaise il faut
passer à autre chose
en revanche si une trop forte division
ou dispersion des votes alternatif jeudi
au mime et au ppm il est clair que ça
risque de ne pas être réalité concluant
mais nous sommes convaincus et nous
travaillons et nous avons d'excellents
autour du tirés des différentes réunions
que nous organisons nous sommes
convaincus aujourd'hui de porter un
véritable projet une manière de faire la
politique autrement en martinique et
nous sommes en train de prouver
pas seulement en paroles mais en actions
qu'il est possible de faire autrement et
nous sommes particulièrement à l'ancien
horaire venir proposer au prochain
scrutin
on va y venir vous semblez dire que le
programme est aussi important que le
choix des hommes et des femmes ou de la
femme et de l'homme les deux sens et oui
les deux vont de pair
effectivement vous dites que il semble y
avoir un désir peut-être de sortir de
cette alternative un petit peu je dirais
deux binômes entre le camp du mime et le
camp du du ppm pour schématiser il ya
des candidats qu'on a entendu la se
déclarer récemment qui semble vouloir
surfer justement sur cette vague qui
commence à peut-être émerger et qui se
présentent mais oui parce que comme ce
qui se présente comme des candidats hors
parti l'a carrément est qui qui
voudraient des candidats représentant la
société civile
voyez le monde économique le monde des
associations et cetera
c'est une excellente chose pour la
démocratie encore une fois et chacun le
doigt
deux prix tendent à exercer les
responsabilités suprêmes au niveau de la
collectivité territoriale de martin
quelque part du point de vue de la santé
démocratique d'un pays ça ne peut être
qu'une bonne chose
en revanche j'insiste là dessus
le cea les lectures de voix qui incarne
véritablement une relève et une
alternative crédible à cette
bipolarisation de la classe politique
entre le mime et le ppm alors d'ailleurs
le nie mais le ppm se ressemblent
beaucoup quant à la conception du
pouvoir au service d'un président du
conseil exécutif tout puissant qui dicte
à une assemblée
est ce que ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il
ya lieu de faire
entre et qui dicte aussi et qui quelque
part méprise un conseil consultatif
parce qu'est la ctm il faut bien
rappeler l'esprit du texte originel de
la loi de juillet 2011
c'est que cette collectivité repose sur
trois piliers un conseil consultatif une
assemblée et un conseil exécutif on va
on va y venir puisque l'on va déboucher
un petit peu la critique ou l'analyse de
la mandature qui s'achève du bilan et on
sait que vous avez à redire sur la
méthode
mais vous n'avez pas dire quand est ce
qu'on saura à peu près je pourrais ces
deux pays à parce que voilà mais c'est
quoi page ou là quelques semaines
d'offres dans deux semaines maximum les
choses les choses seront si je dois
avouer qu'en interne à pia au sein de
pays acp et un choix qui a déjà été fait
mais pas et les grâce c'est parce que
nous traitons encore avec des
partenaires
le choix de pays à effet mais se
pourrait que le choix final ne soit pas
celui de pays a donc nous avons une
autre manière de faire les choses nous
ne disons pas voilà nous avons noté de
l'esa qui les vignes et binou mais nous
construisons y compris avec nos
partenaires c'est déjà dans
l'élaboration d'un projet et d'une
stratégie c'est déjà une autre manière
une manière différente de faire les
choses
alors quelle sera la colonne vertébrale
du programme que vous entendez ou des
propositions que vous entendez faire au
peuple martiniquais l'électorat et au
peuple alors nous nous inscrivons
vraiment de logique de d'amélioration
des conditions de vie au quotidien des
habitants
c'est à dire les problématiques de vie
chère les problématiques de transport
les problématiques d'accès au logement
les problématiques environnementales qui
sont de plus en plus prégnante seront au
coeur de notre projet toutes les
problématiques d'accès au réseau aucun
programme très social et écologique en
tout cas ses soucis de la protection de
l'environnement ce sont deux forcément
ces éléments restent qui ces éléments là
sont inscrits dans notre adn de pia et
cesser ce hack que que le peuple
martiniquais attendait des politiques
publiques qui soient cohérentes dans le
sens d'une réduction de la dépendance
sous toutes ses formes
il ya aujourd'hui une urgence
démographique un pays qui perd trois
mille cinq cents à mi temps par année
depuis dix ans il est largement temps de
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé et d'engager
véritablement des politiques publiques
pour arrêter l'hémorragie est une
urgence n'est pas fait pour vous
suffisamment ce n'est pas fait parce que
c'est un thème d'autres l'ont aussi mais
le retour est jeune et céréales est
clair que ce n'est pas faire comment est
ce qu'on pourra attirer aller vers les
jeunes
ouais mais y'a plus à l'est que de virer
du jusqu'à présent comment est-ce qu'on
peut attirer les jeunes
si le territoire n'est pas suffisamment
attractif si à part les bases d'un
développement économique d'un
développement social sia pas les gages
d'une sécurité sanitaire
environnementale
si du point de vue démocratique nous ne
donnons pas l'exemple nous donnons nous
n'affichons pas quelque part une fierté
une dignité une unité martiniquaise pour
des femmes les dossiers martiniquais si
nous n'avons pas ces ingrédients là on
pourra toujours parler discourir sur les
alevis graisseux sur le retour des
jeunes etc
mais concrètement si ces ingrédients là
ne sont pas présents ne sont pas venus
il n'y aucune chance de changer l'image
que les martiniquais ont de la
martinique
alors évidemment l'analyse voir la
critique raisonnée du bilan de la
mandature qui est en train de s'achever
là ça fera partie aussi de ce que vous
allez dire présenter au peuple ory très
clairement il ne s'agit pas pour nous de
dieu que tout est négatif
tout n'est jamais négatif
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
faites d'ailleurs je rappelle que pour
ceux qui ont l'occasion de suivre des
plénières de la city où c'est
l'assemblée qui prend les décisions et
pas l'exécutif je le rappelle lors de
ces plénières beaucoup de dossiers sont
votés à l'unanimité
heureusement encore que il ya encore cet
esprit de responsabilité de faire
avancer les choses
donc la critique elle doit être localisé
sur la méthode notamment d'un conseil
exécutif et de son président c'est pas
tant sur ce qui a été fait dont une
partie évidemment a été porté par
l'assemblée et les conseillers
territoriaux qui y siègent
mais c'est par la suite comment les
choses ont été appliquées c'est sur les
2 c sur les deux je vous renvoie au
programme du gras semblait en 2015 et
vous verrez qu'il ya beaucoup
d'engagement qui n'ont pas été suivies
d'effet qu'ils n'ont pas eu le début de
concrétisation
donc il faut s'interroger sur sa comment
est ce que on peut venir impunément
vendre des projets aux électeurs
martiniquais puis miser sur l'oubli
c'est à dire en disant que le peuple a
la mémoire courte et et
mais pourquoi cette partie là ce constat
que vous faites l'assemblée ne serait
pas aussi partie prenante finalement de
ce qui n'a pas été fait ou n'a pas pu
être mais l'assemblée a fait beaucoup de
choses a pris beaucoup d'initiatives
dans la décision dans un contexte
hostile
c'est une régression l'application est
compris dans l'application des décisions
des délibérations prises par l'assemblée
ce qui pose un véritable problème
démocratique
alors voilà donc ont bien sûr eu
l'occasion d'exposer sa au fur et à
mesure de la campagne et des rendez vous
que vous allez proposer quelques mots
sur la mobilisation qu'il y a eu le 27
février dans les rues de fort de france
bon on le sait autour du dossier de la
chlordécone et notamment du volet
judiciaire
jean philippe miller mais je suis
j'étais très fier de cette mobilisation
moi j'ai trouvé que cette mobilisation
était il y avait appelé il faut le
rappeler il a été co organisateur de
cette manifestation avec beaucoup
d'autres organisations martiniquaise là
je trouve qu'on a affiché une image très
digne et d'unité martiniquaise le
l'ambiance n'était pas aussi festive
nous avons pu démontrer que même en
carnaval ou ambiance de fête
on peut se réunir et et dire en tant que
peuple à
tout le monde se diot déjà à nous mêmes
et dieu ou notamment à la france que
nous nous ne pouvons pas accepter
l'éventualité d'un non-lieu dans un
dossier qui a fait tant souffrir la
martinique et qui fait toujours tant
souffrir notre pays je le parlementaire
que vous êtes le député est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose qu'on peut faire à ce
niveau là pour justement faire en sorte
que l'état n'ait ne ne donne pas en tout
cas au moins cette impression d'un déni
de justice
vous savez qu'il ya théoriquement la
séparation des pouvoirs entre le le
pouvoir judiciaire le pouvoir politique
quelle initiative pauline île où on peut
prendre mais nous devons là encore
affiché autres parlementaires mais entre
parlementaires et élus du territoire
notamment avec la 7e nous devons
afficher une unité et une détermination
sans faille face au gouvernement
français moi je n'ai jamais participé à
une réunion réunissant tous les
parlementaires les représentants de la
cité m face au gouvernement sur la
question du chlordécone par exemple mais
sur beaucoup d'autres questions et c'est
ce qui manque
les autres savent s'unir savent faire
peuple nous compte tenu des du bal des
ego qui existe depuis trop longtemps
dans notre pays
nous avons beaucoup plus de mal à nous
union pour afficher une équipe solide et
solidaire face au gouvernement pour
répondre aux besoins à des besoins
l'accent et des besoins réels objectifs
du peuple martyr oncle à vous inviter à
nouveau les parlementaires à se
rassembler se réunir pour faire bloc et
je les ai toujours fait ça a été quelque
peu continuer sur ce dossier la mairie
de je veux particulièrement
particulièrement sur ce dossier là si on
n'est pas capable de s'unir et
d'affichés vraiment une solidité et une
solidarité entre nous sur ce qu'est ce
ces questions là pour aller porter des
exigences initiative politique forte
c'est ça que je suis toujours favorable
à des initiatives politiques fortes qui
sont porté collectivement et
solidairement par tous les élus
martiniquais
au delà des différences et ça aussi
c'est l'empreinte pays à il paya aînés
et on le sait 2
cet apport de différents courants de
différents mouvements et c'est ensemble
que nous allons réussir sinon nous
allons échouer et nous sommes en train
d'échouer
parce que trop souvent on considère que
rejoint en solo on gagne et c'est le
peuple qui paye parce qu'aujourd'hui les
dossiers à la ctm sont traités dans des
délais beaucoup trop long et ça pénalise
in fine et le peuple martiniquais et les
porteurs de projets dans notre pays
merci jean philippe miller d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ça passe très
vite là une dizaine de minutes trop vite
mais ça ne fait que commencer
voilà rendez-vous à bientôt bonne
journée merci beaucoup